lisa is with us in colorado hi Lisa how
are you hi as good as I can be
good how can I help I don't tell him
because I took out a loan on my floor
against my phone kay and I just lost my
job and I'm pondering whether I should
pay off the loans or take a hit with the
penalty and the tax do you have the
money to pay off the loan no I do not
have enough cash to pay off for them how
would you pay it off I give you some
cash and I could take out an advance on
the line excited I have okay I probably
would do that because if you don't pay
it off within 60 days it's considered an
early withdrawal as you said and you'll
be charged ten percent penalty plus your
tax rate so if you're in the 25% tax
bracket
that'd be 25 plus ten thirty five
percent and that's a pretty heavy
interest rate yes so that's why we tell
people not to borrow on their 401k loans
are on the 401ks ever because they find
themselves in a situation like you are
in are you married no I'm single have
you landed a new job no I have not mmm
I just lost my job a few weeks ago okay
cool what were you doing I'm an
accountant mm-hmm okay
and having trouble landing an accounting
position
what part of Colorado are you in I'm in
Denver and I don't think it'll be
difficult to land a job
I'm just relocating to Florida because
of the family okay so I'm just kind of
waiting for a good transition period
with my son in his school then I'll move
out to Florida okay which would be like
not on when he gets out for Christmas
right
right because I don't have how are you
living a sin so you don't it does sound
like you owe me money how are you living
well Colorado became unemployment
and I do have savings I can have about
7000 and savings would have my emergency
fund my thousand dollars mm-hmm I'm kind
of bridging my household budget with my
savings and the unemployment and I have
a renter who runs my basement so it
didn't been able to not not digging any
more debt so I'm wondering if there's
some people though you couldn't get some
contract worth work here at the end of
the year right there in Denver until you
get ready to leave I bet you could
probably find a couple weeks worth of
work people doing wrap-up stuff on your
end books yeah I think that's what my
thing was going to be trying to find
some temporary work until you know while
the seasons here people are taking
vacations yeah how much is your 401k you
got it's it's one $9,000 okay I would
not I would not pay it off yeah I would
not pay it off today I want you to get
moved and get re-employed because $7,000
that you have in cash is very precious
right now we need to protect that money
yeah that's always concerned I'm like if
I said should I keep the house or such
chaos alone in which would be the best
option to do well I do want the loan
paid off but I would not use any cash to
pay it off you know I tell you if you
want hit that line of credit and pay it
off with that line of credit right now
and just move it to that at least
that'll keep you from getting hit no
matter what and because I don't want you
to get up to the end of the 60 days and
and not have this done so let's go ahead
and get that done with a line of credit
100% don't use any of your cash yeah
okay and then and then then you when you
get moved if you've got any cash start
your debt snowball which would entail
paying down the line of credit of course
so we're gonna turn around use the cash
but only after the crisis is behind us
and you're square in the middle of a
crisis you've got very little money and
you and you're making a move from Denver
to Florida and you're gonna wait 30 days
or so to do that so you you know you got
to get with this because you got to get
that of the job I think I'd make a trip
or two to Florida and start looking for
a job I don't think I'm gonna wait till
I get there to look because I'd love for
you to start work like the second week
of January in Florida and your sons
his new school yeah let's get let's get
really assertive and proactive on this
whole situation